a certain world champion of 960
wesley soul who is here with us
yes we do have wesley so with us pulling
up one of his wins from earlier he did
defeat peter svidler in round eight
wesley you
were sort of out of it like you were a
distant thought you had to win some
games in order to even have a chance
what made you pull yourself together to
win those two games to put yourself in
the mix uh i don't know i just played my
game without any pressure i wasn't
expecting anything today
uh basically i just wanna play chess and
uh at the very least it's a showdown
anyway so there are no ratings
involved and also time control is quite
short so i was just having fun playing
my game i really didn't expect anything
today i think
after the first day i realized that it's
not my tournament because i missed some
chances
over push against linear and made that
blunder so there's been hiccups here and
there wait wait you're after knight f6
what do you mean you thought that was
not your tournament
i mean yeah
in that game
but you ready you also came down to the
wire against
uh nakamura at the end
you could have actually won that game
and we'd be talking about a playoff
right now yeah i was very happy winning
against fabiano and peter although i
think fabiano had uh basically very bad
off day
uh he just stumbled up yeah basically i
thought
um
all four of us with the five pointers
had black pieces
so i thought that there would be a quite
a safe bet and it proved to be correct
but
the one kind of overpushed
at some point i mean i think in the last
game
the one was doing okay against senior in
a solid position
but uh he just blundered uh and got this
king under attack
um so yeah with hindsight i maybe should
have played for a win but it's also
quite dangerous to to do so against
then they that's why icaru is i mean i'm
quite happy with the tide for a second
because
uh after yesterday i thought i would
finish somewhere the lower half of the
table
but yeah i mean it's it's not an ideal
tournament but
it's it's been fun
all right you come in second what's your
next event yeah um my next event will
overboard will be the youth championship
and before that we have uh
online champions chester by magnus on
dress 24 but i'm not sure if it's
going to happen it was supposed to be in
san francisco
starting september 25th now they're
gonna hold it online
uh but
no details so far yet they're still
figuring out a proctoring issue and who
are the participants all right well we
hope this is a good warm up for you for
those events good luck and we'll see you
back here at the usa mission yeah
definitely yeah my faith uh i'd like to
thank the faintly with jeff club and rex
thinkfield and you guys for hosting this
event it's been a very fun event i think
all the players had fun chess 960. also
what i really like about this event
because we hold it annually is that the
players can gather before the games and
analyze which is basically unheard of
top level chess
all right thanks so much and good luck
thank you
it's